we begin with big news expected today on
the cost of living in this country gas
prices hit another record high overnight
and that's part of why lots of other
essentials like groceries are also more
expensive is there any relief in sight
that is the question new numbers out
today are expected to show we may be
turning the corner but not fast enough
for most americans nancy cordes is at
the white house where president biden
says tackling inflation is his top
domestic priority nancy good morning
good morning nate and president biden is
going to be heading to illinois later
this morning to talk with farmers about
the very real impact that inflation and
supply chain shortages are having on
their ability to grow food and the
farmers we spoke to warned that we could
see more empty store shelves in the
coming
months i know the families all across
america are hurting because of inflation
president biden tuesday called inflation
the country's top economic challenge and
pointed the finger at two causes
the first cause of inflation is a once
in a century pandemic a second cause mr
putin's war in ukraine
and u.s farmers are bearing the brunt
facing higher prices for fertilizer
seeds and diesel fuel are you looking
over
550 plus or 60
just to fill up one time in my tractor
john boyd is a fourth generation soybean
and cattle farmer in virginia he says
his upfront costs have roughly doubled
in one year we weren't able to pay for
seeds so the struggle is real
and
the struggle is going to be real for the
american people in the coming months as
it relates to food krista swanson who
grows corn and soybeans in illinois
worries what will happen to those who
can't cover the new costs farming is a
you know a passion and it's a way of
life but it also is a livelihood and so
you know you have to be able to make
some money just to stay in it on capitol
hill republicans argued the white house
hasn't done enough to help struggling
americans president biden's
mismanagement
of the economy and inflation
has really trapped americans
in an inflation nightmare mr biden
argued the gop is serving up blame but
no solutions what's the congressional
republican plan
they don't want to solve inflation by
lowering your cost
they want to solve it by raising your
taxes and lowering your income
president biden said yesterday he is
considering releasing president trump's
tariffs on chinese goods in order to try
to bring down the cost of goods here in
the u.s and this morning all eyes are
going to be on the monthly consumer
price index report economists looking
for any sign gail that inflation has
peaked
everybody hopes it has thank you very
much nancy